scp-682 vs scp-3108  the hard to destroy reptile may treat  all regular firearms like mere  annoyances but could the legendary  nerfing gun take the monster down a peg  or two the nerfing gun has the power to  turn anything it shoots into a worse  version of itself a d-class was ordered  to shoot 682 with it and after missing 6  times due to fear he landed the lucky  7th shot but it wasn't so lucky 682  became larger stronger and developed the  ability to explode and reconstitute  itself immediately as an offensive  weapon it breached containment and  killed many members of personnel  researcher western theorized that 682  became a more dangerous version of  itself because a weaker more docile  version of 682 would be considered a net  positive by the scp foundation and  therefore wouldn't technically be making  it worse that's one dangerous  technicality